[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Sam welcome to my talk The
Annoying site also known as the power of
the web platform so my name is Feroz I
work on web torrent which is a torrent
library for the web and I also built web
torrent desktop which is an electron app
built with some friends and it was one
of the first electron apps and it just
recently passed 1.5 million total
downloads which is pretty cool and
standard yes as well so javascript
linter that catches programmer errors
and the forces consists of code style in
your projects and it's also good at
angering people which is just good fun
sometimes and if they're doing open
source since 2014 full-time since 2015
and you probably use some of my NPM
packages and my open source work is
supported by many generous patreon
donors at the moment so thank you to all
of those people I just wanted to give a
quick shout out to my most recent
project that I've been working on called
bit MIDI if you follow me on Twitter
you've probably seen me tweeting about
it so it's like a wayback machine for
MIDI files how many people here know
what a MIDI file is raise your hand okay
cool so alright cool so it's it's used
by a lot of people in the music industry
but my first exposure to it was in like
my first days of browsing the web it was
often used with the BG sound HTML tag
for playing audio in the background
automatically when you land on a web
page the good old days back when the web
was fun and quirky and so anyway I
wanted to play some of those I looked
online for basically a collection of zip
file as it filed full of Middies and I
couldn't play it back in any program so
I thought it would be fun to use web
assembly to take a mini player in C and
make it work on the web and then host
all these MIDI files and so that's what
it is you can go there and you can play
around with it it's been good fun it
also gets a perfect Lighthouse score in
Chrome Canary which I'm really proud of
so it's really lightweight really fast
and works on mobile and it's great okay
so it's story time I've been getting a
lot of weird spam in my inbox lately
here's one
the emails you can see on the projector
so yeah stock manufacturers from Zi
Jiang China are trying to sell me what
they call sublimation socks which I
think there's been printed socks and I
don't know it's been waste so much of my
time and it always ends up in my inbox
for some reason it doesn't get filtered
out properly so I was thinking is there
some way that I could waste the spammers
time in return how many of you felt that
before like you know some people they
respond to the spam emails themselves
you know and try to lure the spammers
into like a lengthy conversation and at
the end they like say surprise I'm not
gonna fall for what you did but the
thing is like that way it would waste a
lot of my time as well so I'm not going
to do that so I was wondering what if
there was some way that I could just
send a link to this spammer and to all
future spammers and teach them a lesson
you know waste their time in return so
in the good old days browsing the web
was more dangerous if you visited a web
page anything could happen
so this is an infamous trick on the
early web it was often known as the
infinite alert loop raise your hand if
you've been caught in one of these
before okay oh my gosh
way more people than I would have
guessed in the past so in the past when
this actually worked the only way to
escape from this infinite alert loop was
to force quit your web browser which
would cause you to lose any unsaved work
and that included all of the unsubmitted
forms that you had in your browser and
so modern browsers are unfortunately
multi-process and so alert doesn't block
the browser process anymore which means
that you can just ex out the tab if it
opens up an alert so I open up issues on
all the major browsers explaining to
them that this broke an important use
case for me but for some reason they
closed all my issues immediately as
won't fix this is a good xkcd about you
know strange workflows in these cases
that I like
so in the good old days we had Internet
Explorer we had ActiveX so as I
mentioned visiting a web page had real
risk associated with it you have to
watch out for danger click on a fake
media player and an ActiveX control
would run and it was game over so this
actually is not a real media player this
is actually with a thing where with one
click you start running native code on
your computer obvious right so if only
ActiveX still ran automatically I could
build a really annoying website to send
to this spammer so I think of the web as
evolving through three distinct phases
so there was the early days when the web
was really the Wild West you could do
infinite alert loops he could run
ActiveX and then we we sort of grew up a
little bit we realized security is
important people started using Firefox
Chrome was released in 2008 so the 2000s
were sort of focused on reining back
what the web could do and sort of saying
okay look look let's just really sandbox
the heck out of this thing and make it
really limited and make it just display
documents and not own your computer when
you visit a website but now I think
we're going into this third phase which
is we need powerful features in the web
we need the web to be able to compete
with mobile mobile apps we need
basically as much functionality as
possible to move into the browser so
that I don't need to make a native app
and there are still exceptions to this
where you do need a native app and this
is where you see people often reaching
for electron where you know they have a
website that can do 95% of what they
need but there's like one thing you know
I want to be able to do you know have
something running in the background in
the tray or whatever and you know
there's these few use cases where the
web still can't can't support it but
basically you know you can do almost
everything you need in the web today
which is great we have a lot of powerful
features so a good news for me annoying
website I went to you know I'm glad I'm
glad that the web platform has become
really powerful we have all these new
api's that have been added back to the
web and we can do things like
serviceworker web audio web payments
push notifications web assembly WebGL
WebRTC Web VR and you know all these are
fun to play with and all these have
delightful edge cases that the browser
vendors didn't think about when making
them and we're gonna have a lot of fun
with that today
the web also has a lot of ancient api's
that can't be removed for backwards
compatibility reasons and some of these
api's are so old that I'm sure that many
of you have never heard of them and
they're they're sort of just sitting
there nicely in the browser waiting to
be discovered waiting to be used
in the various ways so I decided to take
a look at each one of these api's one at
a time and try to do the worst possible
thing with them I like this quote by
Paul Boucher it's every system has two
sets of rules the rules as they are
intended or commonly perceived and the
actual rules also known as reality in
most complex systems the gap between
these two sets of rules is huge
sometimes we catch a glimpse of the
truth and discover the actual rules of a
system once the actual rules are known
it may become possible to perform
miracles which are things that violate
the perceived rules so what Paul is
calling miracles are also known as hacks
and so the definition of hacking that I
like a lot is taking advantage of the
gap between the written rules and the
actual rules so if there's no gap then
it's not possible to do something
surprising because everybody already
knows what's possible it's not possible
to hack fortunately the web is full of
places where the written rules also
known as the specs diverge from the
actual rules also known as the
implementations we experience this every
day on the web as well developers so I
didn't think it would be very hard to
find some edge cases and some of these
powerful new api's so I started looking
through various web API is looking for
anything that might help me make a
really annoying website to send to this
spammer
and I found some really weird ones as
you can see up here some of these like
the plaintext tag are just absurd how
many of you have heard of the plaintext
tag raise your hand okay yeah like three
four people it's absurd it it renders
everything that appears after it as
plaintext and there's no way to close it
so if you include it then all the HTML
tags afterwards will just show up in the
page I don't know what that's for but
anyway there's also a string prototype
big and quote which are they're not
really good for annoying annoying
purposes but they're just they're just
silly like if you call big on a string
it just adds a big HTML tag on both
sides of the stream
and quote just adds double quotes on
both sides yeah I looked up with the big
tag does it actually just it makes the
the size of the text one size bigger
than the parent div around it really
useful okay so in all this searching I I
finally found what I was looking for I
found it seriously the best api's window
moved to and their friends
these methods allow you to move and to
resize a browser window I thought there
was no way that these ap eyes would
still be allowed in modern web browsers
sure enough when I I tried them they
didn't work immediately and the reason
is actually kind of surprising it's the
same origin policy can you think about
why moving a window would have anything
to do with the same origin policy huh
sort of no it's actually so it's
actually more and more that if you think
about like when you're using your
browser you usually have multiple tabs
open right and so if one site like say
this site here bit MIDI were to try to
resize the window I would also be
resizing the Wikipedia tab which is
implicitly it's sort of affecting domain
on another origin and that's just not
allowed even though it's kind of a silly
thing it's like I'm just resizing it you
wouldn't think that's a big deal but
actually any kind of you know
cross-origin communication without the
site explicitly opting into it is a
violation of the same-origin policy so
at least that's how I explained to
myself why the API didn't work but I
figured out a workaround for it so if
you open a new window using window dot
open then you get this little window
that pops up and you can see the
parameters there are it's a really weird
API the first two parameters don't work
anymore so you just pass empty strings
the the third one is like a
comma-separated list of of properties I
don't know why it's not an object but
anyway that's what you do and then you
get this little window that pops up and
okay so that's cool now let's try to
move it around so when I wrote this code
and I ran it it didn't work again but I
noticed a little thing in the browser
that said pop-up window is blocked so
you know I did a little research figure
it out okay so what we need to do here
is we need to trigger this window
opening in response to a user initiated
event so in other words like a click or
a key a key press if we do that we're
allowed to open up windows so this works
now let's add the fun part
right so let's see it
so I have a little demo here can you see
that yeah okay cool so if I click this
button you get a window that moves on
its own and if you try to grab it and
move it around it fights you and if you
if you try to right-click on it to the
little right-click thing also the menu
moves too so okay we're off to a good
start this is pretty annoying can we do
anything else and so I thought I should
intercept oh sorry you can see my my
slides here and need to fix that okay
there we go so I thought let's intercept
all user initiated events and let's open
a window on any possible interaction
with the site at all the best part about
this is this includes things like
command W if you try to close the tab
this includes escape if you try to like
you know close if a pop-up window comes
up and you're like escape I need to get
out of this it'll actually open another
pop-up window yeah so you doesn't work
on scroll unfortunately or on any of
those other types of really common
events but like mouse move would be
really ridiculous
but it works on mouse click touch on
touch devices and all keystroke events
so let's just use that little function
we just wrote called intercept user
input and when that happens we will
prevent that whatever the default thing
the browser was going to do and well
instead call up this little open window
function to open a window so one other
trick we should add is so the pop-up
windows can sort of go behind the main
browser window if the user clicks on the
main window and then they'll be moving
in the background which wouldn't be
nearly as annoying as if they were
moving and they were all on the front of
what you're doing so we can just on any
click we can just call this little focus
windows function to bring all the
windows to the front you have to do this
in response to a user event like a click
or something but it works really nicely
ok gets worse
what if we bounce the windows off the
screen edges and so this little bit of
code here you probably gonna be able to
read it fast enough but it just detects
when the window hits an edge and then it
just inverts the direction
okay let's also play a random video in
the window so I have some good ones here
that I found the great part too is so
browsers have started to try to prevent
autoplay Auto playing video that
includes audio and if you try to do that
then the video just will get blocked
however we're setting up this site so
that the user will be tempted to
interact with it in some way initially
we're gonna put like a cute cat or
something and say you know click the cat
to get started or something we need some
way that entice them to do an initial
event in order to get these pop-ups
going and then once they've done that
we'll also be able to play sound because
they've interacted with the site so so
now we've sort of used this API but can
we do more is there anything else we can
add any other API as we can use of
course yes so I'm gonna get into a few
more api's but first one thing is one
thing is worth discussing which is the
permission model for all of these api's
as I was looking into them I realized
there's basically four models that the
browser uses for permissioning each of
these api's so i think of them in this
way so the first one is the API just
always works so API is like that are
well actually I won't tell you the API
as we'll see them as we go so there's so
many P as you can just always use
there's some that you can only use if
you're on an HTTP domain you probably
probably if you've used the Service
Worker you know you have to be on a
secure origin because it's a very
powerful API same thing with geolocation
then there are api's which require user
interaction so this is to play sound for
example and then the most sensitive API
is require explicit user permission and
that's what you've seen with the little
prompt that comes up saying like can I
use your webcam for example so as I go
through these I'm going to hopefully
I'll remember to mention which of these
models each of the api's falls under
okay so the first one we can do is we
can copy text spam text to the user's
clipboard so here we have an array of
interesting ASCII art and we can just
call clipboard
I guess that's actually yeah that's a
method that I that I wrote but anyway
you call it and it copies text to the
users clipboard this API requires a user
in user interaction with a site so if
they click at all we're just going to
fill their clipboard with the cat and
then also a link to our site so if they
accidentally paste it into slack you
know it'll go viral like that okay one
more so we got speaking to the user this
one is great this one's actually really
great so we can we can use this speech
synthesis API which lets you pass text
to a special function and then it will
read it to the user
and so I have these nice phrases here
that I found which are extremely
annoying when read in a computerized
voice especially the a all the A's there
that one is great the best thing about
this API is that it can auto play right
away without user interaction as soon as
you land on the page on top of that it's
also unmute Abul so if you right-click
on the tab and you try to say mute this
site it doesn't affect this API so I see
the chrome engineers in the audience
opening up issues right now I'll try to
go slowly say you have time to keep
opening issues as we go through these
yeah so anyway there's a great API
here's a fun one you've probably seen
before you can ask the user are you sure
you want to leave this page when they're
trying to close your website so you just
listen to the before unload event and if
you set this event return value to true
then when the user tries to close the
tab it's gonna say are you sure you want
to leave you have unsaved changes you've
probably seen this used on like Google
Docs or something if you if it hasn't
sent up the changes to the server yet so
let's just make them have to do an extra
click to close each of these pop-ups
browsers have actually started to lock
this one down a little bit so you need
to at least interact with the site once
before this is allowed to pop up which
is annoying but it's still pretty good
so I'll try it anyway this is a good one
so we can register protocol handlers so
we attempted to register all possible
protocols that the user might
on their computer and then if they oh
this one actually had required explicit
user permission so it's probably
unlikely that they're going to say yes
but maybe in the frenzy of them trying
to close all these windows going on
their screen
they might just give us permission to
handle all their Bitcoin transactions
which would be great might as well try
right while we're at it let's ask for
the camera and the mic one cool thing
about this code is if you look towards
the bottom there's a little function
called tracked apply constraints and
you'll see that I've passed torch true
to it torch is actually the term that
describes the camera flash so if they do
give us permission we'll just turn their
flash on on their mobile device it's
nice this one's good we can vibrate the
device this actually works on Chrome
chrome on Android and we just to make it
even better we pick a random duration
for each of the vibrates so it goes like
really and consistently this one
unfortunately now also requires a user
interaction and it also doesn't work in
iframes anymore because there were ads
that were actually like an ad would in
the iframe would just start causing
buzzes on your phone to attract
attention to the ad so they stopped that
but anyway if they interact at all with
their site which they're going to do
then we will be able to start buzzing
their phone which is nice you're
starting to notice a pattern here
basically like the idea was like you
know let's put some of these api's
behind a user interaction and then you
know that way it can't be abused but the
thing is one user interaction maybe
shouldn't be allowed to cause all of
these api's to run at the same time
right okay we got more Safari has a
feature called picture-in-picture which
allows a video site to pop a video out
that hovers on top of all of your
windows on your desktop so you can like
watch a lecture or something while
you're working on other things so what
we do here is we start an invisible
muted video so that it's ready to go and
then as soon as there's an initial user
interaction with the site we we trigger
the picture-in-picture
and then that pops the video out onto
the desktop and actually chrome is
adding this API to
future versions so that's good for us
this one this next one is amazing this
actually works so we can actually just
take away the cursor that's great now
they can't even now they can't even
chase down the windows and try to hit
the X button it's very disorienting
I also saw another actually somewhat
someone did something even more clever
you can actually set custom images as
the cursor and I saw this great site
where someone actually made it so that
like they basically offset the cursor I
wish I had a video of it but anyway they
offset the cursor down by like 100
pixels in each direction and then they
pop something up that you try to close
but when you actually close it you're
actually enabling a permission prompt
because your real cursor is up higher
it's actually great yeah
Security's hard ok so here's another one
and we can this is a great one too
because I don't know if you've seen
websites where it says if you go to
download a file and then you get the
little countdown timer it's like
downloading in five four three two one
and then the file downloads well what
that what's going on is actually you're
allowed to download one file without any
user interaction if you think about it
right because it's it's counting down
and then it downloads a file and you
haven't even clicked anything so we're
allowed to trigger a file download one
file download immediately without any
user interaction but then further file
downloads have to happen in response to
a user initiated event or otherwise the
browser blocks them and then asks the
user it says like the site is trying to
download multiple files would you like
to allow it so we can just call this
right away and give them a give them
various cat pictures in their downloads
folder and remember each pop-up window
can do this
okay this one is really nice so if they
go to hit command W so I mentioned
earlier that that you can you can handle
you can run events when that happens but
I can't think it's chrome actually
doesn't let you call event dot prevent
default on command W because they don't
want you to be able to intercept that
however there's a good trick that
actually works around this so if you in
response to then pushing command you
open a modal dialog like an alert then
the W actually doesn't it doesn't do the
full shortcut anymore because the the
the dialog has opened up and now it just
sees it as a W so all you got to do is
when they push command you just open a
pop-up and then you open up an alert and
then W doesn't work so that's nice and
we can also very varied a little bit for
good fun so in some of that some of the
time we can call window dot print which
asks if they want to print the page and
that's nice and it doesn't actually it
doesn't require any user interaction you
can just call that as much as you want
let's also just throw in a random modal
alert every 30 seconds just for more
chaos you can also full-screen the
browser this happens on user interaction
as well so we need to have a click but
throw that in there all right
so many of these like I think I'm gonna
run out of time okay so this is a good
one I didn't come up this one but you
can there's actually these URLs which if
you send a get request to them they'll
actually log the user out of the the
given website and what's amazing is you
can actually send get requests
cross-origin right think about it like
every time you've included an image tag
you can include an image to a
third-party website and that image will
load just fine and what is that doing
that's making a get request now of
course if you try to make a if you try
to load one of these URLs as an image
it's not going to show an image but
it'll still make the get request the
data will come back they'll be logged
out and then no image will show so let's
just try to do this a lot of these
actually some of these half of these
don't work anymore but it does actually
log you out of google still and a few
other sites so this is the commercial
code to do that we just we just use I
think xhr here or something like that
yeah and it works
here's another one I discovered so let's
disable the back button this is really
fun look at what it's doing it says if
the user goes back they'll trigger pop
state so if the user goes back just send
them forward it's works and then here's
the thing though so the back button has
like a long press feature where you can
hold down the back button and it'll show
you multiple like previous sites you can
go back to like a whole list of them we
don't want them to be able to use that
to actually skip past this code that
we've written here so what we do is when
they first land on the site we fill the
history with extra entries so we just
push state a bunch of extra URLs in that
are our own site and then we push back
the original URL back on so they can't
tell that we've actually gone through
and you know iterated like added like 20
entries to the list and so now they
can't actually hold down either and and
try to go back okay we got more we can
do some embarrassing searches
try to keep it pg so what we do here is
we can actually once in a while when we
open up a pop-up window we'll make one
of those pop-ups actually point to being
searched and I chose being cuz you know
it's pretty funny on its own but you
know to mean heaven being in your
history now I'm just kidding anyway so
so yeah basically this is the code it's
a little too much to see what's going on
but basically it just opens a pop-up
window and then the interesting thing is
so if you open up a pop-up window and
it's on another domain like Bing com
then you I'm no longer allowed to
control it and move it around because
it's on another origin right however as
long as you have a reference to the
window you know in other words we were
the worse side was the one that opened
the window so we have a handle we have a
variable that references that window we
can't actually okay we can't actually
like reach into the page or do anything
to it or move it around but we can do is
set window dot location on it and
redirect it back to ourselves so we can
redirect you to Bing so that the search
gets added to your history and then we
can redirect you back to our own site so
the window can start to move again and
then redirect you to another search and
then just keep looping like this so the
window Bing windows will actually freeze
once in a while while they're loading
the Bing site but then once we once
they've loaded we redirect them back to
our own domain so that we can continue
moving them around your screen ok this
is ok I think this is the last one this
one is extremely surprising this
probably sit was going to surprise a lot
of you so sites that link to two sites
that include links that open in a new
tab using target equals underscore blank
will actually still open links in a new
window however that new window that has
been opened has a variable set called
window opener and that references the
window that opened it this only happens
if your so if your site has been opened
in a new tab you can check window dot
opener and that will be a pointer to
that window that opened to you okay so
like I said before they're like having a
pointer to a window on another origin
doesn't necessarily help you you can't
really do anything but what you can do
is redirect it so if anybody links to
our site the annoying site and it opens
in a new tab and a lot of site
do this for example facebook Messenger
does this when you click a link it'll
open in a new tab will redirect Facebook
to ourselves in response so this is how
you do that
it's actually really crazy that you can
do this so you can imagine like hooking
a link to go to another site and then
you know that site that was previously
like a trusted site now redirects to a
phishing site or something it's really
bad however there was a way to work
around this you can add rel equals no
opener to all of your links that open in
new tabs and then that new tab will not
have window door opener set they can't
do this by default because it's a
breaking change but you should
definitely do this and all your links to
open in a new window okay cool so let's
see it let's put it all together and
let's see what we got all right okay so
I have chrome here actually let's start
in Safari Safari actually it's more
funny in Safari
all right okay so here we go
so it's telling you to hold down space
for three seconds because that triggers
a bunch of repeated events I could also
just click once but I think it's funnier
if I hold down space so let's do that
okay so some stuffs happening well yeah
I don't think my speakers not plugged in
but yeah they have I've sound going
right now
so the more let me turn the volume down
a little bit okay so the more that I hit
escape the more actually windows open up
so if I like own a scene out like my
computer's actually frozen there we go
all right let me try to catch them these
I think if you miss and you actually
click on the window then you open up
more pop-ups so so I'll try to do
command W instead which to see it opens
up this alert window with like a lot of
cats in it and I think I can hit X when
that happens though that's actually
useful oh now it's trying to print so
I'll just I don't wanna print anything
now let's try command W again
okay so I've hidden command W over and
over again but I'm getting and this is
see this actually blocked the opening
here what if I try to go okay I can't
even hit the window here but if I try to
go back I got all the annoying sight if
I check my notice here too this is the
floating floating picture and picture
window down here and my downloads folder
has been filled yeah so this is kind of
a disaster the easiest way to get out of
it is to just you know quit the browser
that actually works but it's gonna ask
me if I'm sure and then the best part is
if you open up the browser again it's
going to recover all the windows so yeah
if I if I'm silly enough to try to hit
command W to close that one of these
it's going to start it's gonna kick it
off and there we go
so you actually have to go by hand and
mouse click on all the X's and hope hope
that you don't miss yeah anyway so this
oh did you hear that
so I use the speech synthesis API to
whenever I try to close a tab it
actually says please don't go let me see
if I could do that again Stan page
all right
[Music]
I'm trying to exit it right now hold on
okay okay cool it stopped all right and
of course this works across browser to I
can prove it you know I mean obviously
it's gonna work here to frozen for some
reason probably has trauma from the last
time I did it okay this right now okay
so anyway yeah so that's like that like
that site is actually live on the
annoying site calm so yeah you can send
it to your friends today they won't be
your friends afterwards so I actually
sent this to the spammer and I think it
was successful I never got any more spam
from him and I have a few more demos I
don't know if I have time I have to have
like it maybe an extra two minutes to
show for me or things okay cool alright
okay cool so I have some other so this
isn't I didn't add these to the annoying
site but these are just sort of fun fun
demos that I thought would be cool to
show you
so I think I think it's this one okay so
one thing we can do with the move the
window moving API is we can make like
actually interesting games using the
window using the windows so we can like
have Windows that have physics so like
if I actually if this was mine what
happened there yeah so if I you can like
play with it with my mouse
it's really basic physics it's just
gravity and then you know detecting the
edges of the windows so I think it would
be fun to make a game with this if
anybody wants to like try to do this go
for it then we can actually have really
use cases for these API so that they
can't take them away yeah so this is a
fun one okay and then I have another one
so this is a fun one so this one
actually is a window which will find
your mouse wherever it is and follow it
around so if I if I move my mouse it
tries to block whatever I'm doing so if
I try to like close something up here
you know it's gonna it's just gonna
follow me around and try to block me and
here's the best part
if I move really fast and I escape the
window look what it does it still finds
me again so this is really explain how
this works that's pretty cool so what's
going on is every time we move my mouse
and mouse move event is triggered and
that will allow the window to recenter
itself around the new position on the
screen right but if I move really
quickly and I leave the window then what
happens is you know it's it's now not
got a nice move event in awhile and so
it realizes that it's lost the mouse and
it needs to search for it and will
notice it doing right now is you see how
it's jumping back and forth left and
right what is suing is it hasn't gotten
a mouse move event in a while and so
it's moving off the mouse and then
moving back on the mouse and even though
it's not the mouse that's moved it's the
window that's moved under the mouse it
still triggers a massive move event and
so that allows this little
back-and-forth motion allows me to
detect that the mouse is still where I
thought it was it just hasn't moved so I
go off on oh it's still there okay cool
stay there but it does this every so
often and then but if I escape
completely then it does a little back
and forth and I can hear I can actually
show you in slow motion so I have a
version that runs at very much slower
speeds so if I move the mouse you'll see
it's gonna it's gonna follow the mouse
this is running at much slower speed
okay now if I hold still you'll see it's
gonna go off on and it's like oh you're
still there okay I'll stay here for a
while and then I'll test again off on
but now if I escape watch what happens
it does basically like a binary search
so it's gonna try the left half of it so
it does back and forth it sees okay the
mouse isn't there now so now I'm gonna
try the left side of the screen and try
the right side of the screen oh there
you are
found you
cool
alright last one since I'm out of time
this one is okay I haven't actually told
anyone about this one yet you guys are
the first to see it and I'm I'm not
gonna probably gonna show the code until
I do something fun with it I'm gonna
make a game with it but what I can do is
with a single keyboard event I can open
up an unlimited number of Windows not
just one I can open up an unlimited
number that's not supposed to be
possible and yet Oh what happened
Oh probably you might compete I don't
know what's going on here this happened
a moment ago two rows really unhappy
with me oh it stopped there okay well
anyway when it doesn't freeze it
actually tiles the screen with Windows
anyway that's it that's pretty much my
talk if you want to reach out to me for
us on Twitter I'm going to post my
slides there afterwards and my websites
frosted org thank you very much
[Applause]